[Music]
this morning on the dish a seafood
specialist with authentic ties to the
briny deep and one of its star
attractions Luke Holden grew up in Cape
Elizabeth Maine a third-generation
lobstermen who started learning the
trade at age 13 after college he worked
as an investment banker on Wall Street
but saw an opportunity to bring the joys
of Maine's casual lobster shacks to New
York City so 10 years ago I remember
when Luke's laughter first opened here
in New York City partnering with his
lobster man dad he opened Luke's lobster
it was a big hit now with nearly 40
locations across the US and still more
in Japan and Taiwan and their latest and
largest location opened in Portland
Maine earlier this month
Luke Holden good morning and welcome to
the dish
mornin thanks for having so was it the
first look it was at the upper west side
was at the first spots he's filling each
village was the first spot I remember
when it opened I mean what were those do
when you think back on those days what
do you think about it was wild so I was
still doing best in banking when we
opened the first Luke's officer and so I
got there early in the morning to help
set up got back to my desk and it was
crickets for the first couple hours I
was like ah that's too bad like I was
hoping a little bit more exciting they
checked in with me at 2 o'clock and
they're like we're sending your father
back up to Maine we've already sold
three or four hundred lobster rolls it
was a huge head-on they're crazy I got
to ask
you got to point out everything we have
here in the spread I think I can make
most out but please let us know what
we're about to eat so we have our
traditional Maine lobster rolls at the
end there fisherman's feed with new
potatoes corn mussels clams new shell
Maine lobsters we've got our clam
chowder's our jonah crab cake and then
finishing off with a authentic blueberry
Maine pie Wow
what's the drink oh yeah spritzing
giggles so it's okay it's a strawberry
rhubarb puree with fresh lemon juice and
a little bit of sparkling wine on top
perfect for awesome
was this really a side project for you
that it was just sort of this idea of
you know maybe let me just give it a try
yeah really was so I got the opportunity
to grow up in a fishing family on the
back of boats in production facilities
third generation lobstermen built a boat
in high school my brought younger
brother was my stirneman well I
absolutely love the industry I love
being a part of it and when I went to my
dad back in the summer of 2009 I said
hey dad you know there's no great
lobster rolls in New York what do you
think about teaming up to open up a
Shack and he said well what's it gonna
take my dad's always been the guy he's I
said well I think $30,000 today when you
think about $30,000 and then you found
your partner on Craigslist you know we
started like kind of the height of the
recession right and that was that
afforded us some opportunities we've got
some of the great leaders of our
organization today and and they were
with us on day one and they took a flyer
on a restaurant brand a lobster roll
Shack because of the the economic
conditions they needed a job like can I
go back to the Craigslist though how you
found your partner on Craigslist
literally it said something like opening
up a main style officer Shak need a
can-do attitude experience not necessary
do you want to join I got I got five or
six hundred applicants and my partner is
this brilliant guy when Chris graduated
from Yale was writing with food and we
flew him up to Maine he met with my dad
my uncle they're like yeah this guy's
clearly smarter than you are
he seems he seems very honest and very
hard-working let's give it a go well
this is delicious what makes it so
different for us so we're a vertically
integrated group at this one time we
work directly with cooperatives or
fishermen we bring it into our
production facility in Saco Maine and
then we ship it all across the world
so half our business is the 40
restaurants that we we manage own and
manage and then the other half our
partners like Whole Foods 2018 we've got
the global supplier of the Year award
for Whole Foods something that we're
super proud of this vert is vertically
integrated a word that lobstermen use on
the back
I mean this was you brought that into
your business experience its
accommodation in the world's rights and
like it's been super meaningful for us
all often like the concept of fisherman
and dealer and processor there's always
friction it's always like like who's out
to get him and we've been able to snap a
much straighter line build transparency
and Trust in those relationships and as
a result we've been able to increase
boat price and we've been able to offer
more value to our to our fishermen and
get better quality seafood well have you
signed the dish and as you do ask you if
you could have this meal with anyone
past or present who would it be so I
just recently became a father
congratulations thank you and I've been
watching I've been watching my parents
just absolutely adore my daughter and I
think if I could have one meal I do it
with all four of my grandparents thank
you so much if you want more on the coat
holdin looks lobster more you can head
to our website
cBS This Morning Calm